antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction henri sannier
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir un imposant rapport que voici
est la une de l'actualité ce rapport des
sages remis à jacques chirac cet après
midi propose une réforme en souplesse du
code de la nationalité
pas de décision simplement des
recommandations qualifié de très
libérale analyses et commentaires dans
quelques instants en compagnie de
monsieur marc selon président de la
commission de la nationalité
erich honecker à paris pour la première
fois un chef d'état est salement est
reçu par la france au programme des
entretiens des armements économie
jacques chirac face aux patrons forum de
l'expansion le premier ministre tombé de
beaux de baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés le cnpf appel aux gouvernements
riposter aux difficultés économiques
puissent y habitaient là est rentré de
libye le médiateur français dans la
sphère des otages du sud qu assure que
les deux fillettes françaises détenues
par le groupe abou nidal seront libérés
prochainement
le septième art ont des michel auclair
est décédé ce matin à l'âge de 65 ans il
avait tourné une cinquantaine de films
avec les plus grands réalisateurs au
théâtre michel auclair était aussi un
comédien de talent une journée
supplémentaire de détention pour marcel
fontaine jean paul kauffmann marcel
carton les otages français au liban
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
erich honecker est donc arrivé
aujourd'hui à paris c'est la première
fois je vous le rappelle qu'un chef
d'état est-allemand vient en france
au delà de la dimension strictement
diplomatique de l'événement cette visite
symbolique de 48 heures résume en partie
la stratégie du bloc socialiste à
l'égard de l'europe occidentale
erich honecker a été accueilli par
françois mitterrand avec qui il aura
deux entretiens le numéro 1 elle nous
reste allemand on fera également le
premier ministre monsieur jacques chirac
alors au delà de la normalisation des
relations entre la rda et l'europe de
l'ouest monsieur honecker est pour
beaucoup dans l'avancée de la diplomatie
est-allemande pendant la crise des
euromissiles il ya quelques temps il
avait même pris la tête de ceux qui
prenaient la souplesse en europe de
l'est
bref la glace nost cher à michail
gorbatchev a trouvé en erich honecker un
ambassadeur de poids tout au moins dans
les derniers temps philippe rochot
radio classique
ah les anneaux à rostock du ballet des
verts les allemands de l'ouest parle aux
allemands de l'est de la glace nost la
transparence et de la politique de
gorbatchev par la voix d'une radio libre
qui arrose berlin est les allemands ont
repris à leur compte
la restructuration
dans bien des drames à l'allemagne
socialistes à leurs gorbatchev
c'est un débat qui touche toutes les
forces du pays comme les millions de
chrétiens est-allemand la nouvelle
politique du kremlin est même évoquée
dans les sermons
gorbatchev le père et peleman a le culot
d'utiliser des termes du sermon sur la
montagne dans ses discours politique
la glace nost a réveillé l'allemagne de
l'est
le pouvoir laisse aujourd'hui
s'organiser des kirchentag des journées
évangélique à l'image de ce qui se passe
en allemagne fédérale
les ministres sont même invités et se
font parfois eu et quand ils disent nous
avons toujours soutenu ce qui se passait
en urss
l'église est ainsi devenu un deuxième
pouvoir incontestable nous les
communistes nous étions de la vie que la
foi religieuse disparaît très rapidement
quand il y aurait séparation entre
église et état et avec la construction
du socialisme
nous sommes aperçus qu'il n'en était
rien que la fois subsiste ce n'est ce
pas et continue à jouer un très grand
rôle les 10 par contre pensez qu'on ne
pouvait pas vivre dans un état athée et
qu'il fallait attendre la venue dans
notre état ou une unification avec la
république fédérale d'allemagne sous
l'auspice 106 les deux ans changer leur
avis la religion la restructuration pour
parler aux allemands de l'est radio gas
nosta plus d'un thème dans son sac le
pouvoir à berlin doit aujourd'hui
compter avec la transparence erich
honecker à paris pendant un peu plus de
48 heures c'est incontestablement
georges bortoli un succès pour la
diplomatie est-allemande
incontestablement cette visite tout à
fait officielle en france c'est un
nouveau pas vers une reconnaissance
pleine et entière par la communauté
internationale de l'autre allemagne
l'allemagne communiste de l'una petit
allemagne relativement 16 millions
d'habitants contre 60 millions à
l'allemagne de l'ouest
folha bien entendu que ce genre de
dialogue présente toujours des
ambiguïtés monsieur mitterrand et pour
ce qu'il appelle sortir de yalta c'est à
dire pour une europe qui petit à petit
cesserait d'être coupée entre eux
l'europe de l'ouest l'europe de l'est
alors que monsieur necker lui reste tout
à fait l'homme de l'europe partage et de
l'allemagne partager et de berlin
toujours partagé par le mur alors
pourquoi maintenant pourquoi début 1988
moi je suis pour ce que le sommet reagan
gorbatchev de décembre dernier est pour
beaucoup dans cette ouverture non tout à
fait avant cela il ya eu le fait que
monsieur necker a rendu une visite
officielle pour la première fois en
allemagne de l'ouest donc puisque
monsieur cole qui est tout même première
intéressée l'a reçu monsieur mitterrand
peut évidemment le recevoir
et puis il ya ce contexte international
que vous dites qui va plutôt vers la
détente et qui fait que dans ce contexte
là bien président de la république peut
formuler une politique étrangère
française qui aille dans le sens du
désarmement et d'une
meilleure approche des pays de l'est
merci georges après six mois et demi de
travaux presque sept mois et plus de 30
heures d'audition publique monsieur marc
selon a donc remis aujourd'hui à jacques
chirac le premier ministre son rapport
sur le code de la nationalité
imposant rapport vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure de 1200 pages qui se veut la
synthèse de toutes les séances de
travail
je vous rappelle que dans un souci de
transparence il en est décidément
beaucoup question en ce moment la
commission avait accepté les caméras de
télévision près de 400 mille
téléspectateurs avaient suivi chaque
débat depuis le début du mois de
septembre
aujourd'hui les recommandations des
sages s'étalent au grand jour
première constatation les mesures ce
n'est pas bien grave
entrée soyez bienvenue au 6 mars selon
les mesures préconisées sont plus
libéral que l'actuelle législation
bernard cadinot l'idée principale du
rapport et celle ci il faut encourager
les étrangers qui sont quatre millions
et demi dans notre pays à devenir
français
cet effort d'intégration repose sur une
autre idée généreuse la nationalité se
donnent elles ne se demande pas donc
tous les enfants nés en france de
parents étrangers est scolarisé entre 11
et 16 ans sont français s'ils le
souhaitent et le 10 à l'occasion d'une
démarche administrative quelle qu'elle
soit on se déterminent entre 16 et 21
ans
les empêchements sont limités entre 18
et 21 ans pour des motifs graves
terrorisme proxénétisme trafic de
stupéfiants la commission des sages
recommande un effort important
d'informations sur toutes ces procédures
bien sûr il faut sanctionner toute
fraude quand elles se présentent
mais la règle reste l'ouverture à
l'intégration dans la mesure où il y à
adhésion au patrimoine et aux règles de
la nation dans le même esprit toutes les
procédures sont simplifiées et
accélérées pour la naturalisation par
exemple ou bien le service militaire le
mariage mixte
enfin en cas de litige ce serait le
tribunal qui trancherait et non plus
l'administration
alors avant de détailler toutes ces
mesures en compagnie de monsieur marc
selon qui est ce soir notre invité merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je vous
propose d'écouter deux premières
réactions celle d'un juriste le
professeur robert et celle de michel
hannoun un député dont le rapport
consacré au racisme suscite quelques
polémiques au sein de la majorité
écoutez
marc c'est qu'il y avait un formidable
malentendu dans ce pays beaucoup avaient
dans l'esprit que réformer le code de
nationalité ça voulait dire exclure tous
ceux qui ne seraient pas français je
crois que c'est ce travail important
transparent pédagogique a montré que
c'était en termes d'intégration et non
pas en termes d'exclusion et que les
choses devaient être comprise et puis il
montre aussi autre chose c'est que quand
on traite des questions de société
quand on les traite sans passion quand
on les traite sereinement eh bien on est
capable de dégager des points d'accord
des zones de consensus et qui dépasse
les clivages de droite et de gauche et
qui sont bien souvent très très
difficile et mal admis dans le pays le
progrès c'est que la commission propose
d'abandonner l'idée discutable et
contestable que les nationalités
devaient se mériter par une sorte de
serment solennel les gens' l'idée
nouvelle est que la nationalité de
l'étranger kenney en france est un droit
qu'ils exercent
simplement on lui demande de manifesté
l'intention de l'exercer je pense que
c'est cela oui monsieur marc selon pas
facile de faire une synthèse de travaux
comme ça dans la mesure où les sages
venait vraiment d'horizon en voyant le
métier l'expérience de discipline
tempérament de sensibilité comme jour
différentes mais nous nous connaissions
peu nous nous avions peut travailler
ensemble mais je dois vous dire après
six mois de travaux que nous avons tous
presque envie de continuer et des
revirements spectaculaires ou éléments
cités écoutez il ya eu des évolutions et
des évolutions de tout le monde
de moi-même comme de tout ce qui était
qui étaient là parce qu'on ne peut pas
entendre plus d'une centaine de
personnes exposants des idées
différentes venant de milieux différents
important des expériences personnes
différentes et on est parfois même
étonné de celles qui nous ont le plus
frappé sans changer ou alors
véritablement c'est que le revoir le
mandat iso nié tout à fait vos
recommandations elles débouchent sur des
propositions qui sont plus libéral que
la législation existante êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse
entre en très gros en très gros hui sur
certains points mais je dois dire que
pour nous l'essentiel et examinant ce
qu'avait été l'histoire de la france
l'histoire du droit de la nationalité et
ce qu'était la démographie actuelle de
la france qui était la population
étrangère nous pensons que notre
problème est d'intégrer les étrangers
qui sont en france
alors prenons en exemple à renault à 90
nationalités doivent être un instrument
prenons un exemple concret celui des
jeunes de 16 à 21 ans qui veulent
devenir français oui eh bien ils
pourront dès 16 ans et de 16 à 18 ans
même sans l'autorisation de leurs
parents ce qui est une nouveauté par
rapport au droit actuel comme vous le
dites dire je deviens français pourquoi
16 ans parce que c'est l'âge où le gosse
l'enfant sortant de la scolarité pendant
laquelle au fond aucun problème de se
poser a besoin d'une carte de séjour
alors puisqu'il a besoin d'une carte de
séjour pourquoi pas lui dire écoute et
vous avez le droit d'être français
est-ce qu'il est français ou es ce que
vous avez votre carte de séjour et de
deux de 16 de 16 à 21 ans à plusieurs
occasions lorsque ils volent aura besoin
d'une carte de séjour
lorsqu'il devra être recensés pour le
service militaire ou incorporés lorsqu à
21 ans la carte de séjour sera terminée
qu'il faudra qu'ils se décident des
films immense il ne s'est pas encore
décidé entre 16 et 21 ans
on le donnera l'occasion de dire je veux
français vous n'avez pas l'impression
que ce projet va un peu à contre courant
je suis je suis direct dans mes propos
de certaines idées qui sont développées
par des députés des élus de la majorité
actuelle et nous avons entendu toutes
sortes de gens ayant toutes sortes
sensibilités toutes sortes d'expériences
la question que vous me posez c'est une
question que ne s'est pas posé la
question
la commission nous avions une mission
qui est une mission de société nous nous
sommes adressés à la société est et non
pas simplement à l'état une majorité
nous avons dit je prends conscience ce
que nous devions 10,60 recommandations
je croise sur les 200 pages du dossier
vous n'avez pas peur qu'elle se retrouve
aux oubliettes après les élections
présidentielles écoutez je ne je ne le
je ne le crois pas je crois que de toute
façon le ce qui a été fait et ne sera
pas oubliée je ne l'oublierai jamais ce
que nous dit c'est justement monsieur
grossier de la commission du
biculturalisme au canada qui a été une
grande commission chargée d'un problème
au combien passionnel aussi au canada et
qui a travaillé donc pendant des mois et
dont le président à vie à la fin je ne
sais pas si nous avons réglé le problème
mais il est certain que nous l'avons
fait avancer monsieur le président je
vous remercie
dans les territoires occupés de
cisjordanie et de gaza
plusieurs personnalités palestiniennes
ont lancé aujourd'hui une campagne de
désobéissance civile non violente dans
un premier temps il ne s'agit que de
boycotter les cigarettes israélienne
mais oui mais à l'avenir les
palestiniens envisagent de ne plus payer
leurs impôts au fisc israélien
l'objectif final demeurant bien sûr
l'arrêt des procédures d'expulsion
décidée par les autorités militaires
israéliennes à jérusalem
reportage de charles enderlin l'appel à
la grève a été observée massivement par
les commerçants de plusieurs localités
de cisjordanie est ici à jérusalem est
le mot d'ordre de désobéissance civile
est lancée par rama signera le rédacteur
en chef du quotidien palestinien al
fadjr commençons par demander à nos
concitoyens de ne pas fumer de
cigarettes israélienne à partir de
demain
la semaine prochaine nous leur demandons
de ne pas boire des boissons israélienne
ensuite poursuivre l' escalade en
refusant de payer des taxes puis à
l'avenir si nous avons l'aide des pays
arabes d'une plus travaillaient en
israël même si rana signera nous répète
que pour lui l'ol paie le seul
représentant légitime
les palestiniens son initiative est un
événement c'est la première du genre
d'un notable de jérusalem est considérée
jusqu'à présent comme un modéré
un interlocuteur possible par de
nombreux israéliens
il n'empêche l'appel de rana signera été
entendu par la rue palestinienne à
jérusalem-est
de nombreux passants nous ont dit qu'ils
allaient cesser de fumer des cigarettes
israélienne à la knesset le parlement
israélien
des députés de droite ont exigé
l'expulsion de rana signera alors que
des personnalités de l'opposition de
gauche ont estimé qu'il sera impossible
de forcer les palestiniens à fumer telle
ou telle marque de cigarettes
aujourd'hui le premier ministre monsieur
isaac shamir a réaffirmé qu'israël
n'évacuera jamais les territoires
occupés et il a ajouté je cite la lutte
palestinienne dans les territoires
occupés n'est que la poursuite de la
lutte arabe contre l'état juif fin de
citation les autre télégramme de
l'actualité avec rémy roche ensuite nous
reviendrons sur les déclarations de
jacques chirac au forum de l'expansion
c'était ce matin paris 1988 pourrait
être l'année du retrait des troupes
soviétiques en afghanistan
c'est le voeu formulé par edouard
chevardnadzé au terme d'une visite de
trois jours à kaboul fait ministre
soviétique des affaires étrangères pense
d'ailleurs que la prochaine étape des
négociations indirectes afghano
pakistanaise sous l'égide de l'onu
pourrait être la dernière
elle est prévue pour le mois prochain à
genève
le président mitterrand continue à
suivre personnellement et très
attentivement le dossier des opposants
iraniens récemment expulsés de france
il en a assuré le haut commissaire des
nations unies pour les réfugiés qu'il
recevait ce matin à l'elysée au même
moment les pousses du chef de l'état se
rendait à neuilly où les familles des
expulsés poursuivent une grève de la
faim
jacques valade satisfait du rapport
qu'il avait commandé sur l'avenir de
l'université
le ministre de la recherche et de
l'enseignement supérieur en retient
notamment l'idée de la création de
collèges universitaires pour les
premières années d'études et celle du
renforcement de l'autonomie des
universités pour la fixation de leur
statut
mystérieuse tentative d'assassinât
contre le président de la foire de
toulon bernard frank a été blessé de
deux balles tirées par deux hommes en
moto ce matin alors qu'il se rendait à
son bureau il ce soir hors de danger
pour maurice à rex président du conseil
général du var il s'agit là d'un
attentat signé du milieu italien
jacques chirac face au patron c'était ce
matin à paris au cours du traditionnel
forum de l'expansion le premier ministre
a fait un peu de prospective économique
nous allons y revenir
auparavant jacques chirac qui avait
répondu à edouard balladur je vous
rappelle qu' hier soir sur antenne 2
dans l'heure de vérité le ministre des
finances lui avait suggéré du bout des
lèvres de se déclarer candidat le plus
rapidement possible je chirac a déclaré
je suis attentif à ces propos comme
toujours
retour à l'économie le premier ministre
a formulé quelques propositions vous
propose de les écouter jacques chirac
n'est toujours pas officiellement
candidat à la présidence de la
république
mais il a quand même annoncé ce matin
son programme économique aux chefs
d'entreprise en fait c'est la poursuite
de la politique gouvernementale actuelle
réduire personne ne le conteste plus je
crois à l'impôt sur les sociétés encore
de l'art de ce qui a déjà été fait il
faut d'un père qui doit réduire la tva
ça nous y sommes contraints n'y a pas de
terreau l'a dit il faut sans aucun doute
continuer à réduire la taxe
professionnelle on ne peut pas ne pas
continuer à faire un effort sur les
ménages pour des raisons qui tiennent à
la fois à la nécessité de libérer
l'initiative et la responsabilité et
aussi à ne pas prendre trop de risques
sur la consommation
le patron des patrons étaient également
présents au forum de l'expansion sans
répondre directement au premier ministre
françois périgot l'a implicitement jugé
un peu trop timorés dans son aide aux
entreprises
il nous faut préparer la riposte et
cette riposte doit être à la hauteur du
danger qui pèse sur notre redressement
et sur la mise en état de compétitivité
des entreprises françaises face aux
échéances de 1992 à situation
exceptionnelle moyen exceptionnel
depuis pourtant presque barriste dans le
ton comme lorsqu'ils demandent par
exemple une relance fiscale de
l'investissement françois périgot a
réaffirmé avec vigueur que le cnpf ne se
prononcerait pas pour tel ou tel
candidat aux présidentielles
oui les présidentielles dont on parle
décidément beaucoup se profile de plus
en plus à l'horizon pour jacques chirac
le premier ministre a réuni cet après
midi à l'hôtel matignon les ministres
rpm 22 ministres et les responsables du
mouvement
but de l'opération faire le point sur
les textes relatifs au financement des
partis et évoquer la future campagne
électorale
tout laisse à penser que jacques chirac
annoncera sa candidature à la fin du
mois deux dates sont avancées les 24 et
31 janvier prochains
le sien invite herlin et rentrer à paris
aujourd'hui lucien vite herlin et le
président de l'association solidarité
franco arabe qui a rencontré les
ravisseurs de la famille valente à
beyrouth au liban depuis le 8 novembre
dernier lui personnes cinq belges et
trois français sont en effet retenus en
otage par le groupe abou nidal lucien
beat herlin a donné quelques
explications tout à l'heure voici la
première photo en captivité de
marie-laure cinq ans et virginie six ans
elle a été remise à lucien berlin à
beyrouth par leurs ravisseurs qui se
réclament du mouvement palestinien fatah
conseil révolutionnaire cette photo le
prouvent les deux fillettes vont bien
elle pourrait être libérée dans les
semaines qui viennent seront libérés
d'après les responsables du fatah
conseil révolutionnaire avant la fin du
mois de janvier sans contrepartie
vous les avez rencontré six petites in
anger pas pu les rencontrer j'ai parlé
avec les responsables de l'organisation
en question qui m'ont donné des photos
et qui m'avait demandé d'intervenir en
quelque sorte auprès du père pour lui
faire savoir qu'elle ait deux filles
allaient revenir en france dans le
courant du mois ou plus tard le 31
la maman de ses deux petites filles a eu
un autre enfant en détention il ya un
petit bébé alors ce bébé reste avec sa
mère
meyer sera sans doute avec les autres
passagers libéré à un certain moment tu
sais pas quel serait l'avenir
pas d'indication donc sur la date de la
libération des autres otages
les raisons et les conditions de leur
enlèvement en novembre dernier au large
des côtes israéliennes restent
aujourd'hui bien mystérieuse
le comédien michel auclair est mort
aujourd'hui il avait 65 ans michel
auclair a tourné dans une soixantaine de
films avec les plus grands réalisateurs
c'était aussi un homme de théâtre on
l'avait vu à maintes reprises dans des
répertoires aussi bien classiques
d'ailleurs que contemporain l'histoire
d'une carrière contée par gérard delmas
disparu ce jeudi matin à 65 ans michel
auclair ici dans les cinq dernières
minutes
la chine à paris auclair a failli être
médecin et puis après le conservatoire à
18 ans il choisit définitivement les
planches l'écran enfin le petit écran
tout de suite dès 1940 il est réputé
pour les rôles de personnages ambigus de
l'ach de [ __ ] dupeux creed qui à force
de charme en deviennent sympathiques ce
que l'on appelle le good bad boy de son
vrai nom vladimir bugeaud vic origines
serbes
michel ou plérin comédiens acteurs tout
en demi teinte a joué dans une
soixantaine de films depuis la
libération dont ce film en 77 le juge
fayard dit le sheriff réalisation signée
de son ami yves boisset
il faut pas oublier qu'il avait été dans
les années 50 une très grande vedette
dans des films comme manon de clouzot ou
comme les maudits de rené clément
oui je vais vraiment le rôle principal
et puis petit à petit avec les années
effectivement il avait glissé où on
l'avait fait glisser vers des
personnages sensiblement moins
sympathique et voire même franchement
antipathique mais je crois qu'il prenait
un malin plaisir parce qu'il avait un
humour assez caustique assez rude et il
prenait un assez malin plaisir à mon
avis à jouer les sales aux hypocrites et
lâche et on n'est qu'il était
effectivement dans la vie quotidienne
tout à fait le contraire il était même
plutôt à titre très courageux voire même
audacieux puisque il se fâchait quand
quelque chose lui plaisait pas ce qui
lui avait valu quelques solides
inimitiés
je retrouve la petite lueur de lucidité
qui était resté éveillé en toi
comment tu le savoir
question absurde c'est bien qui je suis
la carrière en dents de scie de michel
auclair s'est terminée sur ce téléfilm
encore hynix les ténèbres recouvre la
tête
étrange coïncidence ce fossile histoire
qui joue le rôle de la mort je parie que
tu es en train de proposer d'offrir au
monde une nouvelle it et est ce que par
hasard tu commences va croire qu'il
existe plusieurs vérités on apprend
également aujourd'hui le décès de
l'acteur britannique trevor howard
trevor howard qui s'était révélé dans le
troisième homme s'est éteint à l'âge de
73 ans à londres vous propose de le
retrouver quelques instants dans l'un de
ses derniers films les années lumières
d'alain tanner et les guichets winner
théâtre à présent le vieux colombier ira
à la comédie française françois léotard
le ministre de la culture a confirmé
l'information
jean le poulain l'administrateur de la
comédie française se déclare évidemment
très satisfait de cette décision
les sports le coureur cycliste
professionnel alain bondue abandonne la
compétition il n'a que 28 ans mais il
pense déjà à la reconversion
bondues laisse derrière lui un joli
palmarès deux fois champion du monde sur
piste
troisième de paris roubaix et médaille
d'argent aux jeux olympiques de moscou
la boxe louis gomis champion d'europe
des poids coq abandonne lui aussi la
compétition mais il n'a que 23 ans
gomis est victime d'ennuis de santé il
avait notamment battu un autre français
antoine monteiro pour conquérir le titre
de champion d'europe
explications de jean ma mère
louis gomis dit louis ne remontera plus
jamais sur un ring le france qu'au
sénégal et champion d'europe en titre
des poids coq ne connaîtra plus la
gloire
son regard de gagneur n'est plus assez
puissant invaincu en 25 combats
louis gomis ne disputera pas le 26e
celui du championnat du monde
motif cataractes à l'oeil droit après
les coups ça ne va pas demander au
conseil des droits de l'homme c'est
impossible et le symbole ici deux jours
après voilà j'ai là j'ai découvert la
potence je le dis est ce que tu me vois
il m'a dit non je ne jouera pas ce soir
louis gomis ne voient sans doute pas non
plus bien son avenir son art de
l'esquivé ne lui a pas empêché de
prendre des coups trop de coups son nom
est déjà faible n'a pas tenu à 23 ans
comme l'américain ray sugar leonard il
est victime de son âge s'agit d'une
prédisposition constitutionnel il est
possible aussi que la boxe avec les
chocs directs sur l'oeil et pu aggraver
aggraver la cataracte mais non pas la
créer de toutes pièces
quoi qu'il en soit après son opération
et selon le règlement en vigueur en
france louis gomis n'aura plus le droit
de boxer louis gomis s'en va au faîte de
sa gloire
la boxe en france vient de perdre un
grand champion mais de gagner en
crédibilité et en sagesse une vague de
froid sans précédent sa boîte depuis
quelques jours sur les états unis et
plus particulièrement sur le sud et la
côte est des états unis depuis samedi
dernier le froid aurait fait 22 morts
toutes les grandes villes sont touchés à
commencer par new york
paul nahon les américains l'appellent le
sibérienne express et ce froid polaire
qui s'est abattue depuis quelques jours
sur l'ensemble du pays les états unis
sont pratiquement paralysé écoles
fermées routes dangereuses aéroports
bloqués hier à chicago - 25 new york
cette nuit - 29 d'un verre - 30
plus étonnant dans le sud au texas en
louisiane on grelotte et tous les
records sont battus première victime de
ce froid les sans abri pour la seule
ville de new york
hier la police a ramassé 10000
déshérités qui ont pu passer la nuit au
chaud et prendre enfin un repas les plus
courageux n'ont pas changé leurs
habitudes
la neige et le froid ont malgré tout
partie de la vie américaine
rien d'exceptionnel dans tout cela moi
je suis très bien je suis très bien
habillé j'aime bien le froid et ses
ennemis le froid new york est sec et
égaux rillieux quel âge vous avez 85
n'avait pas froid
non vous me promettez vous j'ai rarement
eu aussi froid de ma vie et les
météorologues ne sont pas très
optimistes pour demain
il annonce à new york sur la côte est
des états unis moins 20 degrés oui forte
heureusement vous allez le voir il fait
meilleur en france il ya aussi de
l'ambiance je retrouve dans un lieu tout
à fait inhabituelle car demain derrière
moi vous allez me suivre se prépare un
petit événement et innovation 6
demain figurez vous que c'est le
troisième anniversaire de télématin
alors oui bah voilà ils sont tous là on
va les applaudir parce que trois ans
comme ça ils n'étaient pas tous leurs
départs non mais c'est pas mal hein il
reste neuf avaient mangé des pâtes oui
beaucoup sont tus peu fatigué le matin
ça ça va les fatiguer également alors on
fait un petit break là je vous laisse
déguster déjà by ap atlanta 6 6 et enfin
ils étaient tous auparavant on va
demander à josé la météo c'est bon chez
vous vous avez bien thaler -20° mois fin
doivent avoir davantage encore nous
aurons droit nous sommes nous aussi un
petit coup de froid mais de courte durée
puisque le redoux est déjà prévue pour
samedi
alors demain matin non attention sur les
routes sur le nord-est où il y aura des
brouillards givrants ensuite sur l'ouest
est bien une
une perturbation arrive à steve
soufflera au fur et à mesure qu'elle
entrera dans le pays
c'est à dire que l'après midi et via des
pyrénées à la vallée du rhône au nord
des alpes les éclaircies seront bête
autant dans le midi quelques nuages
encore sur la corse
les températures donc mon chuter puisque
sur l'est eh bien nous n'aurons pas
davantage de 5° pas plus ainsi qu'à lyon
et y regarder il sera 12 ha breizh et 12
à nice pour une fois il n'y aura pas de
querelles entre ces deux villes alors
demain vendredi 8 janvier ce sera la st
lucia ge propose que ce soit aussi la
synthése matin tandis docteur oui ça se
présente très bien trois saisons d'un
garçon 3 kg cinq projets que vous ne
l'avez préparer pour demain une émission
sous forme petit peu dommage
ceux qui ont la section créée cette
mission enfin william leymergie julien
lepers patrick lecocq question barry
mono j'ai pas tous les citer il y aura
le petit victor qui n'est même jour
d'allégeance oui il est né le jour de la
naissance de télématin on va le
retrouver trois ans après je vais lui
faire dire télématin et antennes de
20h30 preuve leur antenne 2
les matins matin il le dira mais vous
faites pas la fête trop tard ce soir là
quand même bonnes qu'elles n'ont pas
trop tard parce qu'on trouve tous très
tôt parce qu'on se lève très tôt mais
l'invité de télématin demain on peut
peut-être en profiter en lui dans la
main hall a invité les quatre hommes
formidables un universitaire américain
qui étudie depuis un an
télématin pour apprendre le français aux
profs américain c'est tout en longueur
pas mal il s'inspire de télématin
absolument de plus avant il regarde
toutes les émissions il les décortique
l'économie demain matin on parlera de
quoi sur le code de la nationalité bien
sûr c'est alors dans le jour en
politique encore peut-être les suites de
la suite balladur de l'heure de vérité
alors eh bien écoutez c'est parfait et
vous roger qu'est ce que vous faite de
plumes et autres il y aura les séquences
assez amusant avril d'une école
maternelle qui a fait 1 télématin et on
va les voir demain matin une école
maternelle de mons en baroeul
ok eh bien on les retrouve demain matin
comme comme vous tous alors n'oubliez
pas demain matin à partir de 6h45
roger zabel toute l'équipe les infos
avec punch aux rédacteurs en chef qui
est là catherine ceylac marque hautement
qui est là aussi
j'en ai oublié il faut pas qu'ils m'en
veuillent bien lisse qu'elle a essayé je
la verrais bien sûr voilà alors adrien
couchepin
on arrête là ils sont tous là vous les
avez vus et vous les retrouvez demain
matin à partir de 6h45 enlève notre
verre bon anniversaire télématin bravo
attendait encore une chose à dire en ce
cas là ça se termine pas comme ça ce
soir
3h30
mais avant cela n'oubliez pas 22h25
édition spéciale consacrée au crédit à
ces pièges
nous ne sommes pas concernés nous
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir